hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar on the
bio gx
sars coronavirus 2 reagents for bd max
systems bio gxr's coronavirus 2
assay has recently been granted
emergency use authorization designation
by the fda i'm christine jewell of
labyrinth
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by bd for more information
on our sponsor
click on the sponsor logo on the left
side of your screen or visit beauty.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as
many questions as you want at any time
you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send also please notice you
can share this webinar on your personal
social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event and just under
that social
sharing tab on the left side of your
screen you will also notice
resources tab where you can download
fact sheets and a full ivd menu
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or you can use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
we have four presenters for you today
nicos pavlidis
vice president and general manager
molecular diagnostics and women's health
at cancer
at bd dr patrick murray vice president
of scientific affairs
at bud celine roger dalbert scientific
affairs director
at bd and joining us for our live qa we
have dr diane kawa
clinical professor of pathology and
laboratory medicine
university of louisville school of
medicine
nicos pat celine and diane welcome
you may now begin your presentation
thank you uh um i'm mikko stavlet is the
vice president and general manager for
our molecular diagnostics and women's
health
and cancer business at bd
uh thank you all for taking the time to
join us today
especially under the challenging
circumstances
and pressure that we're all operating
and the goal of our a
teleconference today is to provide you
with
background and details on part of the
solutions that we are delivering to
help you manage this crisis related with
the pandemic of coronavirus
and what we're going specifically to be
talking today is about
our bd max solution and
the essay that we developed and
delivered to you
uh for sars called two testing
to do this we have a panel of my
colleagues an expert on the call today
and we have our vice president of
scientific affairs
dr pat murray we have our vice president
of research and development
for the diagnostic assets celine
and roger delbert and we have our
director of scientific affairs dr diane
kawa
uh moving into what we will be covering
today
i'll just take a couple of minutes to
share with you some background
on what with the rpd and a bit more
specific about the bbmax molecular
platform
and then my colleagues will will focus
into the details related with the essay
covering some of the aspects around the
instructions for use
looking into the specimen types the
result reporting
and the limitations related with assay
and we will have plenty of time to get
as many of your questions as we can and
hopefully answer
most of them today
jumping straight into what we do
at bd we are a global medical technology
company
and today we are reaching more than 190
countries across the globe
we are a 65 000 assorted strong team
and each one of us is driven by our
purpose advancing the world of health
the way we are pursuing our purpose is
by delivering innovative solutions to
researchers and healthcare professionals
and the innovative solutions we are
focusing and delivering
is around the advancement of medical
research
is um around
supporting surgical and interventional
procedures
supporting the management of diabetes
and
enhancing the diagnosis of disease and
cancer
which is also one of the topics that we
will be focusing
today so specifically when we start
looking into
enhancing the diagnosis of disease
one of the solutions that we have been
focusing over the last few years
and specifically looking into the
molecular diagnostic
testing is our bd-max system
the bd max system is is is a versatile
fully automated molecular platform that
we have been commercializing in us over
the past few years
and it focuses around a couple of areas
that are important for diagnostic labs
today
we are focusing on standardizing the
workflows and procedures within the lab
this is happening through the level of
automation of the bidimax system
and we're focusing around driving
efficiency
within the labs this is all designed
into the standardization of the assays
that we develop
and the ready-to-use reagents and the
versatility of the platform
uh also focusing on the ability to
utilize
the platform with a significant menu
that we have been developing over the
past few years
and we have been focusing on healthcare
acquired infections
into entire infections into sexually
transmitted infections and
women's health as well as delivering
solutions
to labs through the open system
capabilities
of the bdmax system that can enable you
to validate
your own lab develop tests
and so that's part also
of our efforts here to try to enable you
through having access to this platform
to get access today to a rapid assay on
the bdmax system
that can help you detect coronavirus and
manage
the volume of samples that is coming
through your lab
having said that i'm
introducing now and passing over the
discussion
to my colleague dr murray
thank you nichols for the introduction
what i'm going to do is talk about some
of the challenges
that we're confronted with with making
the diagnosis of the sars coronavirus 2
and some of the solutions that we at bd
are trying to provide
so i think the the first step that we
have to think about
when we think about diagnostic testing
is the comp
is the complete picture of diagnostic
testing and so that includes both the
pre-analytical considerations as well as
the
analytical considerations under the
pre-analytical
we think about the specimen type that's
going to be submitted to the laboratory
the collection device that will be used
for that specimen
and the transport conditions that are
available and then
in the laboratory we think about the
test platform
the test assays and whether or not
they're being performed with the
approved specimen types
and collection devices so as we think
about
the pre-analytical side i think it's
important to think about where these
specimens are coming from this is a
respiratory infection
primarily and most of the specimens are
collected
from the from the nose but the nose
actually is a complex
anatomic structure we have
deep in the nose is the nasal nasal
pharynx
and then midway out from the nasal
pharynx
is the mid-turbinate area
and then you have the nares or the most
exterior or anterior portion
of the nose and it becomes important to
recognize these
anatomic differences because
the way the specimens are collected is
going to
be dependent on where the swab is going
to be
used so in both the nasal pharynx
and the mid turbine area it requires a
very narrow swab to be inserted
into the nose to be able to collect
those specimens
in contrast for the nares it's a larger
swab
and it's easier to be able to collect
that because
it's just in the anterior section of the
nose
now i point out these differences
because it becomes very important to
think about
what specimens are considered by the fda
as appropriate for collection
and what specimen swab should be used to
collect those specimens
and so up until recently the only nasal
specimen that was considered
acceptable was the nasal pharynx and
that required a very thin swab
a flock swab that was inserted into the
nasal pharynx by a healthcare provider
more recently in roughly the last week
we've seen approval of
collecting specimens in the mid turbine
area
and again this is excuse me this is with
a flock swab
but this can either be collected by a
health care provider or it can be
self-collected by the patient themselves
but this is only permitted for patients
that are symptomatic
very recently we saw the approval of
collection of specimens from the
anterior portion of the nose of the
nares
and what was unique about this specimen
was that foam swabs were permitted
to be used for these specimen
collections it was recommended that both
nostrils be
swabbed and then that can either be done
by a healthcare professional
or it could be self-collected by the
patient and again
these are only for symptomatic patients
it's also approved that
we can collect oropharyngeal specimens
with a flock swab with a foam swab
or now with a polyester swab and again
these would be collected by a healthcare
professional
and can be has to be combined with a
nary specimen
and if the patient has lower respiratory
tract symptoms and is producing sputa
then the sputum specimen would also be
considered acceptable
now i walked through this area because
it's very important to realize
that the flock swabs the ones that are
used to collect nasopharyngeal specimens
and mid turbine specimens
and the foam swabs which are approved
for the nares
are made in very limited keep in
capacity
and in fact we can't produce enough
swabs to be able to satisfy the
diagnostic
needs and so that is the reason why
there's ongoing work
trying to prove alternative swabs like
the
uh polyester swab or or
a rayon swab and we're hopeful that
within the next one to two weeks we're
gonna see approval of using those swabs
also for the collection of specimens and
when that occurs then we won't have a
limitation
on the number of swabs that are
available for specimen
collection specimens also have to be
transported and again
up until recently the transport media
that was acceptable was the universal
transport medium or a viral transport
media
or one that was developed by the
laboratory itself
more recently we've seen approval of
amy's transport media
and phosphate buffered saline and in
particular the phosphate buffer saline
again allows us to collect large numbers
of swabs
for transmission to the laboratory
finally the transport conditions uh that
are uh approved by the fda is that
specimens will be collected at four
degrees centigrade
they can be transported for up to 72
hours
or frozen uh and that that would be
useful beyond 72 hours so we still see
some limitations in both the types of
specimens that can be collected the
types of swabs that can be used
and the transport conditions but we're
optimistic that we're going to see
improvements in that so that that won't
be the
limitation of the amount of diagnostic
tests that need to be performed
the next kind of consideration is the
platform itself
and again what we what we see is the
approval of a large number of platforms
that can be used to be doing tests for
these types of specimens
i'm going to focus on the bd max and
this is sort of a
broad picture of the bd max
demonstrating
the variety of different types of
specimens that have now
been approved for use with bd max
for the sur test this is a test that was
available
uh in in europe
and it was used for diagnostic testing
for our european customers more recently
we've seen now the introduction of the
biogx test which is what we're going to
focus on in today's conversation
and then um also we have a bd specific
test that was developed
with the open system reagent components
of the system the flexibility of the max
is really quite remarkable and the types
of assays
that are available for doing testing
but the the real focus is on the the
biogx test
which has been launched launched under
the fda emergency use
authorization um
we expect and maybe maybe very soon
we'll have the
approval of this test for widespread use
the next slide is just to illustrate the
fact that
we have prepared reagent kits that are
available both for running the test as
well as running
the controls for this test uh available
for the bd
bd max so let me now transition
to celine who can talk a little bit
about the analytical performance
of this particular test
thanks pat for the introduction okay so
i would like to quickly
review with you vsa design its
performance and limitations
the vsa design as pat said earlier
is based on the most recent cdc design
incorporating both n1 and 2 targets
but also rnsp as an endogenous control
any positive target will result in a
positive rna detection
for covid19
so a positive test results for covid19
indicates basically that rna from the
virus was detected
and the patient is infected and presumed
to be contagious
obviously laboratory test results should
always be considered in the context of
clinical observations
also epidemiological data in making a
final diagnosis
and a decision regarding the patient
management
a positive results as well do not hold
out
bacterial infection or even co-infection
with other viruses
when it comes to the negative results
for this test it means that the covin-19
rna was not present in the specimen
above the limit of detection so
negative risers do not preclude copy 19
infection and should not be used as the
sole basis for patient management
decision
negative results must be combined again
with clinical observations
patient history and epidemiological
information
the limit of detection of esa has been
determined
in poor negative clinical samples with
genomic
rna well quantified and the
lod is described as the lowest
concentration
of genomic rna from covid19
that can be distinguished from the
negative samples greater or equal than
95
of the time the limit of detection for
vsa
is currently established at 4k
genome equivalent pair ml of vtn
so it's an extremely sensitive essay
the performance of vsa on the vdmax
platform
has also been established with
retrospective
collected mesopharyngeal swab
clinical samples we have been using
30 individual negative clinical samples
and 30 contrived positive samples
from patients with signs and symptoms
of an upper respiratory infection
low positive and moderate positive
contract
clinical samples were prepared by
spiking again
quantified genomic rna into the
individual negative samples
the spiking level was at 1 and 2x
led but also 3 and five x
logs all the 30 samples
were positive and all the negative
samples were negative
in the background of the individual
clinical sample
as this essay is under eua
classification
there are obviously some limitation
that we would like to highlight
so this essay has been evaluated
only for use in combination with bd
max tna tree extraction kits
and on the bdmax system as patch said
earlier
reliable results depend on proper
sample collection storage and handling
of the sample
right now the test is intended to be
used
only with mesopharyngeal or pharyngeal
swaps
collected in the bd uvt
system of propane universal transport
media
the testing of other samples types has
not yet
been validated
as with any molecular test mutations
within the target regions of the virus
could affect primer and or pro
binding which could result in a failure
to detect
the presence of a virus however
as the algorithm required only one
target to be
positive to report a positive
detection of rna the risk of mutation
impacting sensitivity is limited there
is
redundancy built in vsa design
due to inherent differences between
technologies
if you are switching from one technology
to another one
the users had to perform method
correlation studies
in their laboratory to qualify the
technology and the differences
and 100 agreement between the results
should not be expected
because of the difference between the
technology
false negative or invalid results may
occur
also due to interference we have a
control with vsa the rnsp
which is an endogenous control it will
help to identify
specimens that contain interfering
substances
but it can also help to verify the
quality of the sample
we have done some testing with
interfering substances
toporamycin for instance can interfere
at vsa at high concentration
the essay has not yet been evaluated for
patients
receiving uh the intranetally
administered influenza vaccine
so i will stop here thank you for your
attention and now we would
like to open it up for questions
thank you celine and thank you pat and
nicos for your informative presentations
and welcome diane we will now start the
live q a portion of our webinar
now to our audience if you have any
questions
please enter them now just click on that
ask a question box located at the far
left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started we have so many
questions coming in already
let's start with this one is the bd max
assay approved
by fda
thanks christine this is nicos yes
it is we submitted the emergency use
authorization
um a few days ago
weeks ago and we received the
emergency use authorization just
yesterday
just to confirm as well that we have
been in line with uh with the fda
guidance
we have been distributing the assay
since the 20th of march
that was the time that we completed
our internal validation and verification
thank you nicos celine let's come over
to you for this question
can you discuss the timeline from
development
to eua authorization
yes sure so it took us exactly four
weeks
thank you nikos let's come back over to
you
what is the supply for the u.s and how
are allocation decisions being made
yeah we we have been able to
start ramping up the production for the
bd max reagents over the last
few weeks last week we were
and this week we were able to deliver to
our customers
just over 20 000 tests and
we continue wrapping up the production
we expect to have available
as of next week 50 000 tests and more
for the u.s market
thank you niko diane let's come over to
you
we are struggling to eliminate the
frequency of internal controls
can you help clarify the control process
for this eua
assay thanks christy
i think this question is referring to
the external control
in the biogx package insert it is
recommended
that one external positive control and
one external negative control
be run at least daily now the external
negative control is intended to detect
reagents or environmental contamination
or carryover
by target nucleic acids the external
positive control
is intended to monitor for substantial
reagent failure
the package insert recommends various
types of external controls for the user
to select the most appropriate controls
for their laboratory control program for
instance
two suggestions are offered for external
negative controls depending on whether
whether a lab has
actual negative clinical specimens or
not
the frequency of control testing should
really be determined by the lab and in
accordance with applicable regulation
for instance the cap guidance says that
cap accredited laboratories must perform
quality control
each day of testing for patient um
samples
and so uh it's really the laboratory's
responsibility
to consult with the accrediting body and
determine what the frequency should be
for testing controls
thank you diane celine has this test
received eua
by the fda and does this test
have the capability to analyze results
on its own
and assign an outcome of detected or not
detected
so yes as nicole said earlier this test
has received eoa by vfta
as of yesterday so the test requires
some user interpretation of our results
because we have two different targets
and these targets
are detected independently in each of
the master mix
and a positive result in either master
mix
is interpreted as a positive
thank you now our next question how
early from exposure can the test be able
to catch
positive viral load
so this is celine i i can try also to
answer these questions
very very limited data um right now
available on um
the capability of all the essays on
markets
regarding uh how we can catch positive
versus when is the first clinical
onset so it's very hard to answer
specifically for these steps
so this is pat this is pat murray let me
let me expand on celine's comment when
we think about
the ability of a system to detect a
positive
sample it's dependent both on the
patient and the state of illness and is
dependent
on the limit of detection of the system
and maybe celine can
add a further comment on limited
detection but in terms
of the of the patient
what we've seen with this particular
corona virus
is that at the time they present with
initial
symptoms they have the peak shedding of
virus
so we would expect that they would uh
produce very large quantities of virus
and that's been the experience with some
of the other assays that
have have been developed
for detecting this organism and so
generally it's not a problem detecting
patients early in their course of
disease as the disease process
progresses the level of virus tends to
fall
and so it may become more of a challenge
for some of those patients
celine do you want to make make a
comment on the limit of detection
of this particular assay yeah sure i
i saw we have also have received this
question so the limit of detection
is currently established at 40 copies
per milliliter of uvt
um it's quite sensitive to be harnessed
um compared to over slaves on market as
well
thank you both now dyan is this assay
considered a confirmatory test
for the copit19 strain and does this
does the institution need to validate
the assay
and one more part do you have data or
instructions on how to conduct the
validation
verification okay so thanks
christy and i would address this in in
three parts
so just for clarity the biogx reagent
for max is not considered or described
as a confirmatory test
as noted by celine in her presentation
positive results are indicative of the
presence
of the sars coronavirus ii rna
clinical correlation with patient
history and other diagnostic information
is necessary to determine the patient
infection status
positive results do not rule out
bacterial infection of co-infection with
other viruses
in similar vein negative results do not
preclude sars coronavirus infection
and should not be used as the sole basis
for patient management disease
decisions um negative results must be
combined again with clinical
observations
and the patient history and
epidemiological
information so in response to the second
part
the answer is yes according to cap
guidance cap accredited laboratories
will need to verify
the performance specifications of
eua kits such as the bio gxr's
reagents for max and this should happen
prior to testing and result reporting
as is required for the cap accredited
laboratory
now bd has developed guidelines to
assist laboratories in verifying the
accuracy and reproducibility of these
reagents
and in those guidelines there are two
suggested procedures
now the first one uses contrived
specimens that are prepared by spiking
negative clinical specimens
with control material from biogx
and the second procedure suggests
use of viral transport media or utm
media that is spiked with the same
controls from biogx
so in essence many laboratories will use
clinical specimens that they do have on
hand and the strategy is normally an
equal number of positive
or negative clinical specimens but the
verification guidelines that bee has
developed
provides an opportunity for labs to do
verify the
performance by using contrived specimens
either in a clinical matrix
or in the vtm utm matrix
i must add that these verification
guidelines are available on request you
can reach out to your molecular
application specialist
for if you have additional questions
about these documents
thank you diane and i'm seeing this
question come in multiple times
do i have to perform linux linearity and
lod
validation as well and what about
precision validation
okay so i will i will take a stab at
this and then maybe celine can talk a
little bit i think she's already
mentioned
the lod of the assay so
the fda authorization for eua
kits do not really require validation by
the labs themselves for lod
determination so they're not really
considered
ldt so if a lab was developing their own
ldt
then they would absolutely need to do
those validation studies
so um the lod determinations are made by
the manufacturer
and are provided in the package instance
so you would find that information
that celine mentioned in the bio gx5
packages according to cap guidance and i
mentioned that earlier
is that um laboratories would need to
verify the test performance
and i've already talked about that in
the prior
prior response and
they must follow the test procedure in
the package insert
as authorized by the fda meaning that
there should be no
alteration of the procedure that is
described in the biogeous pack packages
and for testing
specimens now so i mentioned
also that for determining precision
or accuracy of the assay in performance
verification
i mentioned earlier that labs need to
use well characterized positive
and negative specimens
thank you diane slain did you want to
add any input to this question
i may just want to add that if we look
at the fda
recommendation in the faq they recommend
that when you
use a new essay you confirmed
five non-positive and five non-negative
and i think it's uh one of the questions
i have also seen
um so that should be also an appropriate
way to
validate psa
thank you celine and let's help you
answer this question
the package insert i received has a
process
to set all the parameters for the test
will there be a software update sent
with the kobit 19 test kits
so there will not be a software update
since we are leveraging here the
capability of a vdmax system
to run open system reactions
so in the packaging search you have what
we call
a user defined protocol or udp
and this is the only option for this
essay
when you set the parameters for the
first time
they are then saved in your system and
you can
reuse them systematically when you run
this essay
your molecular application specialist
can also help you
as needed so you can contact him or her
and the udp will also be available for
email with service
and celine how long can the
reconstituted qc remain at negative 20.
so i i suspect the question is about the
external controls
so if it is the case i think the user
will have to
follow the package insert of the
suppliers for the control
but likely some of these controls are
stable few days at minus
20.
diane do you need to add 25 ul of
rehydration buffer
to the beautymax conical tube in
position 3
this is from the exktna 3 procedure
thanks christy i think this person
asking the question is referring to
how one would normally set up an ldt on
the bd max
but with the bayou gx stars coronavirus
reagents the components come
pre-packaged
and so the user will find these
ready ready made tubes that are easy to
snap into the different positions
of the unitized reagent strip so in
short order there's no need for the user
to individually
rehydrate the buffer themselves and then
put that into position three
so they need to follow the procedures
and the packages that it's clearly laid
out of the different steps and what
reagent goes into which
position on the unitized reagent strip
thank you our next question are these
reagents
suitable for biomark hd real-time qpcr
system
i can take this one right now the bio gx
is sa is validated with the tna
tree extraction kit on the bd max
only
thank you and danielle must have you
answered this one
um what are the safety precautions when
using the instrument for covet 19
testing
thanks christie so the overarching
guidance here
is that lavatory is performing covid19
tests
including the cells the bio gx5 reagents
on the map should refer to the cdc
website for
general guidance on biosafety practices
standard precautions etc when handling
clinical specimens now clinical
specimens
all of them should be considered
potentially infectious and handled as
such
now standard precautions would include
hand hygiene
use of personal protective equipment lab
coats and gowns
gloves and eye protection as i mentioned
that these would also apply to using the
biogx reagents in the laboratory
now one thing one should point out here
is only personnel proficient in handling
infectious
material and use of the biogx reagents
on the mac system should be performing
the test
now clinical specimens for testing with
a biogx reagents
are tensor to a sample buffer tube and
these are clothes with the piercing
septum
cap now these are all designed and
implemented to
reduce risk of exposure during sample
processing
so overall we do encourage laboratories
to follow the guidelines that have been
set out
by the cdc for covid19 testing
thank you diane saline let's have you
answer this next one
will vtm be an approved media type
yes it is so uh we currently have claims
for
all foreign german mesopharunal swaps in
vtm or utm you can use either of uh
bd or the copan branded btm
i know there is also a question i have
seen earlier on
m4 as well that's a recommended
collection kit pair the fda
in their q a and there is no reason to
believe that it will not work with vsa
but all our validation has been done
with the copper
and the dvd branded vtn
thank you now diane let's come over to
you
what qc are you recommending what about
acrometrics
qc with low pause and lod
that's a great question christy and i
mentioned
earlier when i spoke about the need for
external
and controls when running the biogx
assay so r d has
worked with three different vendors qc
materials produced by
biogx themselves and these control
materials
have specific controls for the sars
coronavirus
n1 and m2 and they also have an rna-sp
control in their kits we've also
validated the controls from biogx and
they have a synthetic rna template that
can be used
as control and finally idt
also has controls that can be
used and these are targeting the nuclear
capsule gene for assad coronal virus
control
and they also have a portion of the
rpp30
gene found in humans would would in
essence also be an rna-sp
control so what the r d team has done
is ensure that these controls are tested
at a level
that are sufficient that would qualify
as a positive control
so i have heard some customers are using
various
input volumes of this but we want to
make sure that the recommendations
are really consistent to what is
appropriate within
less than 10x of the lod of the assay
and so
what we have done is developed a white
paper where we describe
each of these controls that r d has
validated
and how to prepare them to prepare
external positive controls
for running on the thoughts by usia
assay of course the external
negative controls we defer to labs to
either use
negative clinical samples all go to the
package insert for
guidance on how if they don't have
clinical samples to use so
this document i believe is also
available on the fda website um
together with the eua authorization that
we got
but we are also happy to provide this
document to
laboratories that need some additional
guidance
i'm also aware that several labs are
looking at different controls
so for instance this person is asking
specifically
about the um i think it's with acro
acrometrics
so rnd has not validated that so we are
not able to speak
to a certain level that you're able to
test with that particular control
so i would defer to you to
validate that control and then see if it
works with the biogx
reagents on the mat there are many out
there so understandably
labs are wanting to use what they have
but we do recommend these three
thank you is the virus viable
once we put blue caps on to run on bd
max
our bd max is in a different room from
the biological hood and we are worried
about
safety walking through the lab with
buffer tubes
so and i'll take that and celine please
feel free to add if you have any any
thoughts
so i mentioned earlier that part of the
process just
pro as processing this clinical specimen
on the max is to put
some of it into a sample buffer too you
know because that's the starting point
for starting the assay
now we there is no data that r d has on
the virus neutralization within the sdt
but we think it's unlikely that the
virus will survive that stage
also remember that after the clinical
specimen is transferred into the sbt
there is a piercing
septum cap that is put on and that
helps to minimize the any potential risk
so it's in the contain
it's it's contained and that sample
buffer tube is put on the bd max
instrument and the run it is started and
in very short order we have the license
step that occurs so
we believe that um this process helps to
mitigate the risk
you know associated um well with
doing this testing we do not really have
data on virus neutralization as i said
but overarching the reminder again that
laboratories
should be implementing the the general
safe biosafety practices when
handling specimens suspected of having
the virus
as with any other clinical specimen that
is potentially
infectious in the laboratory
okay our next question apart from the bd
controls
can the sites use controls for
microbiologics
i will take that yes so microbiologics
like i mentioned is one of the controls
that b
r d has actually validated and it's a
single control
it's a synthetic rna standard it's
representing a segment
a thousand nucleotide segment of the
sars coronal virus
and nucleocapsid gene and that
represents the n1 n2 and n3
and the assay itself the bigex assay
targets the n1n2
so the biogx control will be an
appropriate
external positive control for the assay
again um rnb has worked it out and
figured out the right solution to test
so so that you're not overloading your
your external positive control for
testing but we do
recommend you follow the rnd guide
thank you diane now what drug was
mentioned
that will interfere
it is to promising
but it's a high concentration
thank you celine is this a high
complexity testing
it has moderate complexity uh rating per
fda
yeah you just just want to to see lynn's
comment um they the this is described
even encountered use
of the assay and it's um
for using labs that have moderate and
high complexity
thank you our next question has bdb gun
validation
of the alternative collection sites and
swaps
how would you suggest labs go about
validating since the paperwork does not
have this validation currently
so let's uh this is pat let me let me
answer part of that question then i'll
defer
to diane about recommendations for
validation
um bd has been working with a consortium
of industry representatives
including roche
thermal fisher and the major swap
manufacturers
copan and puritan to work
with the fda and with other
other independent groups to look at
alternative swab
types and alternative specimens
and we're confident that over the next
week or two weeks we will see additional
swabs
uh introduced into the marketplace
that'll allow us to
really meet the the diagnostic
testing needs that exist dan do you want
to
comment on validation of let's say a
polyester swab
with a nasal specimen so so actually
for clarity the verification guidelines
that we have
are um for using contrived specimens
in the vtm or utm matrix not specific
swap type
and so so again the the the assay has
been authorized to nasosyringelan
oropharyngeal specimens on in utm or vtm
which are at the information it's either
the cocaine or the
or the um bd ztm
so the procedures pack are for spiking
in
control so contrived specimens in a
negative
clinical matrix and so do not really
specifically look at alternate
swap types one thing we do recognize
that the fda in fact just yesterday they
had you know an update we
frequently check to see what the new
guidance is
with regards to alternate transport
media or alternate home swap types
the verification guideline recognize
that liquid amis and um
of phosphate buffered saline are
alternate
transport media that the fda has
recognized
so even though we those have not been
validated for the sake of the
verification guidelines we do make a
note that
laboratories can consider those as well
for the verification
spiking in into those matrices but they
need to be validated by the lab so
the verification guidelines were
developed based on
data coming out of r d or has been
vetted by
r d so we cannot speak in those
guidelines about the alternate transport
media
and i would defer to your earlier
comment pat about
what bd is doing about the alternate
collection
swaps which i know there's an ongoing
activity
around that i hope that clarifies the
question
thank you diane and we do have time for
some more questions but
we have so many questions coming in i do
want to remind our audience that
any questions we are unable to answer
live today and those that come in during
the on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
okay let's keep going the testing is
limited
by the nationwide nationwide lack of the
utm for collection
that you attach to your eua have you
performed
studies using other media
i'll take that since i just sort of
responded to that christy
oh so no um again i know that there's
internal work going on
looking at the alternate specimen types
in transport media etc
so that is going on but in terms of what
we can
actually guide laboratories with right
now
are the verification guidelines that
suggest that labs can consider
the alternate transport media that i
mentioned um
physiological saline pbs or liquid amy's
for their verification studies and
remember the verification you need just
a few
specimens positive or negative whether
actual clinical or comprised uh to do
the verification
and but you would need to to assess
those
alternate transport media to see if it
really worked for you on in your
laboratory
until uh bd again we're actively working
on those
questions because we know everybody it's
a
priority for everybody
thank you now is this product available
for the canadian market
yeah this is nikos no it's it's not
available for the canadian market
and as we indicated we're working on the
bd assay
which we are exploring the options to be
registered with health canada so an
update
should come there from your team the
local canadian team
soon and i maybe just to take
one more questions one more question
christine
related with what hardware is
required to use the rc you need to have
access to the bidimax system
very good thank you nicos what is the
run time for this essay
two hours 45 minutes
2 hours and 45 minutes thank you well 24
samples
for 24 samples how often
does the udp need to be entered or
altered
the udp needs to be entered only once
and when it's saved in your system so
theoretically speaking you don't
have to do any updates
very good thank you have you done
carryover studies during the testing
we are seeing a lot of positive patients
and maybe
that's just the way it is but would you
recommend running a blank tube in the
middle
of each run
so in terms of carryover studies
for our eu mission we leverage
existing data we had with these
extraction kits
and viral targets so the short answer is
yes we have done
um this study but with a different model
than this virus
we didn't have any carryover or
cross-contamination during the study
we recommend usually to have external
controls
as diane explained previously so you
should have
a negative external control that will
verify for contamination risk
thank you n1 is positive
n2 is nr can this be reported positive
yes the algorithm um
has been built in a way that you can
report results
as soon as one of the two target is
positive
and the idea is first to limit the
number of repeats
but also ensure the highest sensitivity
possible
and it has it helps to create redundancy
also
by having two targets that are
um reported separately
thank you and we have time for just a
few more questions
how long is a sarb uh copa2 pcr
run for 24 samples i'm sorry let me
repeat this
how long is sar coronavirus 2 pcr run
for 24
samples and how long does analysis take
so as i said before it's two
hours and 45 minutes for a full run
you can start loading new samples after
an hour when your extraction is
completed
regarding the results you will get
results for
both of your targets on the screen of
the bed bbmax
so there is no further analysis
to complete
the validation or verification
regulations are also
oh pardon me are the validation or
verification regulations
also necessary for high complexity cliag
laboratories as well
anyone wants to take this question
hello hello christy
yes can you hear me yes yes i can hear
you yes let me let me try to
see if i can answer that question okay
according to cap
according to cap guidance you know all
cap accredited laboratories
must verify the performance of a
manufactured
um test diagnostic test kit prior to
implementing for patient testing and
reporting results
so i would say yes the answer would be
yes
at a moderate or high complexity
laboratory
that is a requirement and um the basic
requirement is to determine or verify
the accuracy
and reproducibility of the of the assay
and using known or well characterized
positive and negative steps
so it's entirely up to the laboratory
how many they decide to use
and there's several um for inspect 31
a offers suggestions for what labs could
do
but a number of tests or positives and
negatives
but it's ultimately the laboratory's
responsibility
and again for the sars essay in
particular the verification guidance
guidance document
that we are offering laboratories does
address
accuracy in reproducibility testing
over a two-day testing period by two
different
operators so and again laboratories are
able to adapt that and modify those
protocols
again it's just a suggested procedure
for verifying
the size essay
thank you and does anyone have any final
comments for our audience
yes christine thank you this is nicos
first of all thanks a lot for
the number of questions and the
interactive session
uh we are all focused and this is our
priority to enable
testing for corona virus across our
bdmax customers
and please reach out to your bd teams
for any additional questions and support
as you go through the implementation
and use of the test and we
have as a priority to support humanists
through this pandemic and manage the
number of
samples and patients that that
all we all try to support and thank you
for taking the time today
we will be coming back to you to with
answers to the questions that we will
not be able
to to answer today
thank you nikos now before we go i do
want to thank our audience for joining
us
and for their for their interesting
questions and i would like to once again
thank nikos tavlidis dr patrick murray
celine roger delbert and dr diane kawa
for joining us today and their important
research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor bd for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
you may continue to submit your
questions
during that demand on demand period and
as we mentioned those questions we did
not answer today live
and those questions that will come in
during that period will be addressed by
our speakers via that email address
you provided at the time of registration
now labyrinths will alert you
via email when today's presentation is
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon stay
healthy and have a great day